for everyone 7.8 billion people for 100
million companies for
everyone with money on earth and
everyone that earns a salary on earth
this is the big idea of the podcast you
have to
yeah i feel like i can rule the world i
know i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking
what's up everybody
we got a special guest in the house
michael saylor
the um have you heard the nickname they
give you on youtube
the giga chad have you seen this one i
might have heard it once or twice
so michael um go ahead charlie
i was going to ask you something have
you heard this nickname that they give
that they gave michael sailor the crypto
no the community you know sort of give
it and take it away
you know they are extremely passionate
and uh devoted
but they are also you know just nuts
online like my
my twitter mentions are unusable now i'm
sure michaels are the same
just because of that group but they are
funny also so they they nicknamed him
the gigachad
because he is sort of like probably the
most
credible established person and company
with microstrategy to
adopt bitcoin in a major major way and
really
um is driving the kind of institutional
pickup of it so if you're listening this
you've never heard of michael saylor
the reason to listen to this is pretty
interesting guy had a really interesting
career but most notably uh
most known now for basically using his
company microstrategy and buying
about two billion dollars worth of
bitcoin or they own two billion dollars
with a bitcoin bought about
i don't know how much you guys put in
half a billion or a billion
no um we uh
we bought uh 2.2 billion
worth of bitcoin we own about five a bit
more than five billion depending upon
the day
wow more than five billion in bitcoin
okay all right so you uh
you you have a for not everyone's gonna
be able to see this but you have a
ship behind you right
like a huge what is that it's an
antique handmade model a 19th century
model of a 17th century
galleon like i think
a model to amsterdam a a galleon that
sailed out of
amsterdam in the 17th century
and it was uh it was made
in the 19th century so it's a very
interesting
piece are you um are you a car guy
i have a bunch of cars but no i'm not a
car guy
what's the coolest one you have i i lean
toward
suvs i have a bunch of suvs i had
had a a lexus convertible that i used to
love
that i drove a lot but i i don't really
drive a lot so you can go so you can
give sam a great sam just sold his
company came into a bunch of money and
he bought what what did you buy sam
okay so i was driving at all this
weekend and i've been getting made fun
of i can't believe people are making fun
of me do you know what an
amg station wagon is like a mercedes amg
i can imagine okay so basically
there's mercedes which is everyone knows
mercedes and then there's amg which is
like a subsidiary and they basically put
race car engines
into cars um and i bought this
but the problem about fast cars and cool
cars is that they're like super
unpractical mostly and
but i wanted something that was like
kind of fast and fun to drive but i
wanted to be more practical and there's
this thing called an amg e63 wagon it's
a station wagon it looks like a mom car
except you can put your dog in the back
and it has five seats and but still goes
zero to 60 in three seconds
so i bought a souped-up station wagon
like the one of the fastest cars in the
road but it's a station wagon
that's my that's currently what i'm
driving right now it works for you
well i was looking for someone to geek
out on it but i guess that you're you're
i would have i for some reason i pegged
you as a car guy but i guess i'm wrong
um i'm more into boats and planes than
cars what do you what what does that
mean if you're into planes
well i like i like aircraft because
if an aircraft can go mach
89 or mach 85 you're allowed to legally
fly it that fast
is mach 8 like 2 000 miles an hour no
market five like uh like 500 knots
like or something like that so the point
is like airplanes can fly
at their full speed and and yachts or
boats can go at their full speed over
the water
but an automobile that could go 160
miles an hour
you don't very often get to do that
legally so
so i i like vehicles that you can
operate
at their design point legally and safely
well what planes do you have healing as
an engineer
i have a global express xrs
um before we get into bitcoin stuff and
because shawn's been talking about you
for like a year now
uh because he was following a micro
strategy and all that but
um you own a a ton of domain names right
yeah i bought a bunch like how many do
you own now
or how many have you i won't count all
the i mean i own hundreds and hundreds
but the ones that are
are top level primary domain names about
i like words in the english language
that everybody
understands like i own emma uh frank
i own my own name i own michael.com
i also own my nickname mike.com
uh so like my personal website i've got
it on michael.com you just type
michael.com you see all the stuff about
me
hope yes sam go go to hope.com see where
that takes you
go to hope.com yeah well actually
bitcoin is hope so if you type hope.com
you get everything there is a know about
bitcoin
i actually repath hope to all of our
resources and materials uh
speaker i i owned voice.com
i sold it for 30 million dollars a
couple years ago that's the largest uh
naked domain sale in the history of
domain
tell the short version of that story the
story is kind of crazy i've heard it
once before but i i would assume
sam and most people have not heard the
story of sellingvoice.com
you bought all these early on in the web
you kind of recognized oh these are
these are probably going to be valuable
to own these names there's only one
you know there's only one owner of each
of these names you own it and you hold
it for a really long time like over a
decade
and uh at some point you decide okay
maybe we should see
if somebody wants to buy some of these
so tell the story of sellingvoice.com
real quick
well yeah we i i bought all these
domains because i thought wouldn't it be
great to own a part of the english
language i mean
owning hope or owning voice i mean
eventually there'll be a google voice so
there'll be
you know some some telco company that'll
want to launch some service and what a
great domain
on to launch on the on a word like
voice.com
so we held them a long time and and uh i
think at some point we were looking for
joint ventures we're looking to
commercialize them and we did
commercialize a bunch for example i
created a company called alarm.com
and alarm.com is now publicly traded on
nasdaq it's
like four or five billion dollar market
cap company
and and you can guess what it does it
actually integrates your home alarm into
the internet
you know and i created another company
called angel.com and we saw that for a
bit more than 100 million dollars and
that was actually a speech
interactive voice response like surrey
or alexa before
siri and alexa came along and uh
so i had voice and i was holding it and
we're looking for some kind of good
uh commercialization and someone out of
the blue
they contacted us one of the domain
brokers
and they said well you know do you want
to sell it we'll give you 150 000.
uh and i you know i was like
someone came to me said they often fifty
thousand i said no so
i thought nothing of it because i just
i couldn't see the point a week later
they come back and say well they doubled
it to 300
000 i said tell them no so
a couple days later they go well the
broker's really insistent uh and so they
went to six hundred thousand
i said no so they said well
what should you say i said don't tell
anything tell them you know like we're
not interested
it's got to be something serious so they
went to 1.2 million
i said tell them no
i said well they want to know what you
want for it
i said um well
send them a note or something and just
tell them i said it's like
it's it's the word voice in the english
language right so
it's gonna have to be something you know
north of uh i don't know i don't think i
said seven or eight
eight figures but i just said a lot of
money
um and so it went on and they doubled
again to two and a half million
and then uh and then uh
five million and then around 10 million
then i said they said i had like 18
people in my office they're like or not
eight but eight eight people they're
like
looking at me like aren't you are you
gonna take the money it's like a lot of
money now i said
uh no send them back uh
at this point send them back an a note
pointing out that this is like
the word voice in the english language
and it's and it's
it's worth a billion dollars to the
right company
and uh they said well you're gonna give
them a response i said uh
okay tom 30 million
tell them i'll take 30 million for it
because i thought like
if i didn't give them some number they
would stop negotiating after
you know five no's so i said tom 30 man
i don't want to sell it for 30 million i
want to sell it for 100 million or more
but i guess i'll say 30 million
so that so at that point they said well
you know they offered you
i think they upped their their offer to
like
12 million i said tell them uh no but if
you want i'll take a meeting with them
so when it got to 12 million i said i'd
get on the phone for half an hour
so then we got on the phone and the call
started with someone saying well
how about 22 million and i said um
let me explain this is like my daughter
like i'm willing to i'm willing to like
marry her
off but only to a man that values her
more than i
value her so i value this
domain you know at 30 million
and so if you don't want to give me the
you know i'm going to regret after i
sell it anyway i'll have
sellers remorse but i would i would do
it just to make the market
but if you don't want to value the 30
i'll just keep it
like uh okay we'll give you 30. i said
okay
so 30 you went you got a 30 from 100k
so they did like double seven or eight
times and i eventually
they started 150k i think and we ended
it
and i said 30 we ended at 30 but but the
point was
i didn't really need the money it was a
matter
like if i had at the point maybe 600
million in cash in the bank
and the company the micro strategy was
is a multi-billion dollar company so
i was like a million is not going to
move the needle for me a hundred
thousand's not going to move then needle
for me five my
ten million is not going to move the
needle one way or the other so there's
no point
in doing it unless it was something
material
were you all like you know the eight
people in your office were
were they like your co-workers or uh i
mean
business development the people that
wanted the commission on the deal
you know so like any any most
likely they want to like do the deal and
and the only way you get 30 million is
to like say no to 22 million right
and well like any reasonable most
reasonable people
which the reason you are where you are
is your many would probably consider you
not reasonable right i mean you have
your
your extreme personality type and that's
why you're very successful
but any reasonable person would say what
are you an idiot
like you paid nothing for this take it
were you but were you
always that like uh my view on it is
that
the english language is going to be
important to the human race for a
thousand years and a thousand years from
now
voice will probably still have value
just like
a lot of like hope it's a valuable word
forever i mean until you murder everyone
that speaks the english language
if you think about how valuable it is my
real view is
is i think people are are crazy for
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
on ad campaigns
to market a brand that's a misspelling
of a normal word
it's like i got to convince you how to
sell ingention
with like two y's and a z you know i'm
like
why would you do that because in the
modern era spell checkers
when you try to type these crappy brands
that are misspelled that you know your
iphone
unspells it for you or properly spells
it so
try going to a website that's a
misspelling of a name
most brands and most brand consultants i
just disagree with them all they
you know they charge you a lot of money
to come up with a misspelling of a
common word
and then you spend half a billion
dollars marketing the brand
a much better idea would be by the word
hope
or angel or alarm or alert or
or voice even if you got to pay a
hundred million or 200 million or 500
million dollars
because if i see your br your ad and you
tell me that you know your brand is
alert.com
i can remember it in one second i can
spell it in one second you leap
immediately to the top of the google
search engine
so i just i always view domains as being
undervalued and then mark
people spend hundreds of millions of
dollars on crappy marketing
to send someone to a place they can't
spell that they can't remember
i think the world will gradually come
around to that point of view but they're
not there
yet but that so that was my view like i
didn't want to sell it to tell you the
truth
like if you owned the word
angel or the word alarm or the word
hope or voice like the truth is google
should have paid a billion dollars for
the word voice
i mean if they're going to try to launch
a voice service it's worth it to them
and eventually
you know what you're going to see is
apple amazon facebook google are just
going to keep generating more money but
the word voice or the word hope or the
you know fill in the blank any kind of
positive
uh positive easy to spell short
word in the english language is going to
be an awesome place to build a brand
and so right now it looks like you own
are you owned or
or you're currently trying to reach me i
own this strategy
wisdom.com alarm.com angel.com a
a alert courage mike.com voice.com
usher.comhopespeaker.commichaelmikesailer.org
so you own a bunch of them
yeah and so and so my view is like like
trying to sell the i got 20 picassos and
i wanted the world of market
to value picassos so i sell the first
one for 30 million
but the next one i want a 100 million
for or or
i really want you know someone to create
a
a billion dollar business with me on
that
right that's the right way to think of
it and i mean i
look at it this way how many people have
learned that
have learned to speak english on earth
what is that number two billion
maybe how many how many
years of your life do you learn do you
spend learning english
i mean a typical person spends it takes
english 10 years
like from kindergarten through 12 maybe
12 years
but let's say that we shorten it 2
billion people spend 4 years of their
life
and that's 8 billion years
of time spent figuring out how to spell
and type your brand
what's the if you value the 8 billion
years at 20
an hour that's 160 billion dollars worth
of money
spent teaching people that hope is a
good thing
right what's it worth like
what's it worth like to have a brand
which is universally understood and easy
to spell that's burned into the head of
billions of people you know you couldn't
you're going to go and buy advertising
to convince them that
h-o-o-p-e is a good thing
hopi or like not really
so i i think that um they're just good
investments they're scarce real estate
and cyberspace
and they'll always be good and the world
undervalues them but
in time like when i tell you alarm.com
you can remember alarm you can go type
alarm
when you get off this podcast anybody
that wants to go check out what
alarm.com does they don't have to go and
like
look it up and sort through 197 000
google search pages
to figure out which one is the one that
sailor was talking about yep
my friend uh started com.com.com the
meditation app
and uh the first thing he did was get
the domain basically
and uh he decided early on art i'm gonna
build a brand around the feeling of
being calm
and it took the form of a meditation app
but he sort of decided up front what it
was gonna be
and had got that domain and really like
had to negotiate to get it and
it was you know these domain
negotiations go prolonged but but
definitely another uh i don't know
success story of that that pattern and
i'll remember
it too by the way like like what you
just said
you just pitched me on an idea i'll get
off and if so
off this podcast and if four weeks from
now someone asks you
so what was that meditation business
thing i'll be like
c a l m
dot com right hopefully they got the
right spelling of it
right yeah no there's three l's no i'm
just joking it's the it's the right one
um all right so let's let's talk about
works let's talk about something else so
you
you uh you've been in the game for a
while i think you might be
how long you've been this you've been
like the ceo of microsoft 30 years
almost
since 1989 so 31 years i've been the
public company ceo since 1998.
i think sam was born in 1980
public company yeah you've been you've
been a publicly traded company
or a public ceo longer than i've been a
lot
and so uh and you've kind of had some
ups and downs so
i i saw an interview of you on charlie
rose
um you know you were looking like tom
cruise you go on charlie rose and
they're you're flying how you're a 34
year old guy who
took the company public i think
microstrategy was worth 11 billion
or something at that point and uh and
best of all i think you owned half of it
or maybe a little bit more than half of
the company
and so you're you know a 34 year old
billionaire and i think you know a few
years later the stock price crashed
pretty dramatically uh but you
i think there's two kind of remarkable
things a i want to hear what was it like
to be in that position and then face
that crash
and then b how the hell did you keep
your job was it because you owned a
controlling stake in the company because
most ceos cannot survive a
stock price crash from 300 something
dollars a share to
under 50 cents a share how did that
happen
you know i think if you if you're in
business long enough you're gonna have
setbacks
and you know you can't let the setbacks
crush your spirit or or
or cause you to stop thinking and stop
innovating and stop growing so i mean
they're humbling
uh well we all kind of know that's the
right answer
but like when sorry we all kind of know
that's the right answer like hey
setbacks happen you gotta pick yourself
up and
that's true and everybody sort of agrees
but when it does happen
what like do you remember what that felt
like what the day was when
when when you're experiencing this crash
what were you thinking as it was
happening
it's not pleasant
it's not pleasant but you know you have
to move on
right yeah you have to focus you have
responsibilities
okay and you're you were talking about
at one point you're like
all right when i was selling this domain
when did you sell that domain name how
many years ago
um two years ago maybe okay so not that
long ago actually but you were saying
like well we had
i had 600 million dollars in cash with
the company was doing great
why continue staying as the ceo
when it seems like you're incredibly i
mean bitcoin seems like you're
one of your main top two focuses next to
microstrategy
why not just focus entirely on that as
opposed to continuing
continuing to run this business well
first of all the
the business has two strategies and the
first strategy is we sell
business intelligence software to our
customers
and the second strategy is we acquire
and hold bitcoin
that is the business got it and
um and and if you look at what we've
done
we um we
bought uh 250 million dollars worth of
bitcoin
that we had generated as a publicly
traded company so without the business
we couldn't have bought the first 250
million of bitcoin and that required
you know an intricate set of of um
due diligence and disclosures then we
did
a dutch tender offer but basically it's
an an
equity offering of sorts of you could
think of it that way but we did a
we did um a reverse
dutch auction and with the res at the
end of that point we bought another 175
million worth of bitcoin
and so that's another thing you have to
have to be a public company to do
then we swept our cash flows as a public
company into bitcoin we bought
50 million more bitcoin and uh without
the company couldn't have done it
then we did a convertible debt offering
for 650 million dollars of debt
at 75 basis points and without being a
public company we couldn't have done
that one either we bought bitcoin
and then it went up again and then we
did we bought some more with cash flow
and then we did a billion dollar debt
offering
and we did that billion dollar convert
offering at zero percent
interest you couldn't have done that
without being a public company
so there are benefits to being a public
company public companies are credible
they're really the gold standard as a
counterparty
right i mean there's a hundred million
companies in the world
there's only about 4 000 publicly traded
companies on u.s listed exchanges
so it's a very very rare thing
you have to go through a huge amount of
of compliance
you know we're we're filing 10 queues
10ks
we've got a lot of a lot of compliance
architecture security architecture
i'm signing sarbanes-oxley statements
you know every quarter right we're
responsible for
fcpa you know
et cetera responsibility so that gives
that gives investors comfort with a
publicly traded company
so probably the most important thing to
to take away from the podcast
is bitcoin is
an exploding uh asset class it's it's
really
it's it's the greatest treasury reserve
asset
of our lifetimes and it's the solution
to every company's treasury
problem so if you have a corporation
that has
capital or generates cash flow you can
immediately
double or improve the value of the
company or dramatically enhance the
value of the company
simply by changing your treasury policy
so
if you take with cash and you invest in
bitcoin
you have inves you've converted a
liability to an
asset and so so
i was enhancing the value of the company
by pursuing the bitcoin strategy
they go together they're synergistic so
let's let's lay out the the kind of the
context for people who don't know
exactly how it all played out because i
would say in our audience right we're
going to get about 300 400
000 listeners this month and in that
audience probably
you know five percent are as crazy about
bitcoin as me
um and have put like you know you know a
huge chunk of their net worth
into bitcoin and then you know fifty
percent are curious and fifty percent
are novices let's say you know just
roughly rounding things out and so just
to put into context
microstrategy is this couple billion
dollar public company it's been around
for a while has a good track record
has a business selling enterprise
software you generate a ton of cash your
business spits off cash you have about
500 600 million
i'm just using fuzzy numbers doesn't
specifics don't matter
you use about 500 600 billion dollars of
cash that's your treasury
for your company and you're looking for
something to do with it and at some
point
you realize you have this treasury
problem and um
and you're not alone actually all
companies have this treasury problem
whether they are
aware of it or not so can you describe
the treasury problem
that you experienced and you experienced
it at a 500 million dollar level but
anybody including an individual with 500
000 or about you know 100 000
in the bank has the same fundamental
problem so explain
the treasury problem as you saw it a few
years ago or yeah
the treasury problem is that subsequent
to march
2020 the cost of capital exploded from
eight percent to 25 percent
and uh you can see that in the
performance of the s p 500 index which
went from about eight percent a year for
a decade
to more than 25 in that next year
that means that anybody investing money
on behalf of a
of a limited partner or any other
investor
has to generate that cost of capital in
order to avoid destroying wealth
if you inve if you generated less than a
eight percent yield for the decade
from 2010 to 2020 as a financial advisor
you destroyed wealth because the
alternative was just to buy the spy
index
if you generated less than 25 from march
of 2020 onward you destroyed wealth
because you could have made 25 actually
a bit more depending on what day of the
week you measure it or what day of the
year you measure it
you could have generated that much just
by owning the index
now um the pro the treasury problem
is that when the cost of capital is zero
if by the way the cost of capital is
being driven by the expansion of the
money supply
the federal reserve is expanding the m2
money supply by about
five to six percent a year
for that decade and when you tack on the
risk premium you get to your 8
s p return when the when the federal
reserve expands the m2 money supply
by 20 to 25 that's where you get that
explosion and the cost of capital
the inflation doesn't show up in
consumer goods the inflation immediately
shows up in assets
we have asset inflation within minutes
of when uh the central bank uh decides
to stimulate the economy
the price of all the assets explodes um
and so the problem for every company all
100 million companies
in the world every private company every
public company the problem is
you have capital in your treasury and
that capital has to yield the cost to
capital and if it doesn't
you're destroying shareholder value
another way to say it is if you generate
cash and you put it into the bank
account to pay zero interest and if
if the cost of everything you want to
buy goes up by 10
a year in seven years you'll only be
able to buy half as much you've lost
half of the value of your savings
when that discount rate or that cost of
capital doubles
well then in three and a half years
you've lost half your money
at a 25 cost of capital in three years
you've lost half your wealth
so the treasury problem is
the cost of capital has exploded and the
cost of capital
as it goes through the roof puts every
company in a quandary
they either have to decapitalize and
give all of their assets back to their
shareholders
because they can't if sam is controlling
an investment company that invests in
dollars
and you are running an investment
company that invests in the s p 5 index
and i gave each of you a million and sam
proudly tells me how he didn't lose my
money
and you tell me you made 25 return i'm
pulling all my money out of sam's fund
and i'm putting it into your fund so
ultimately that the problem is the
company's sitting on capital if it can't
meet the cost of capital
it has to give the money back to the
shareholders or at least it's under
extreme political pressure from the show
everybody's beating you up as ceo saying
what are you doing with all that cash
you should just pay a dividend
or you should buy the stock back and um
and the second pressure you have is if
you run
a company and your cash flows are
growing at eight percent a year
but the cost of capital is 25 a year
that means that i'm discounting you at a
rate that's higher than your growth rate
in essence the value of your stock is
going to be forecast to go to zero
you can't hold value in a company
growing at
five percent a year when the cost of
capital is 25 percent a year
that's why the only thing you can buy is
going to be a high-tech
stock that's growing you need to buy a
tech monopoly that can grow 20 or 25
a year and if you come to me with a
business idea for
a company which makes a lot of cash or
is makes a lot of money but it's growing
two percent a year or one percent a year
i'm just not interested in a high cost
of capital environment
so the problem we faced in march is
what do we do give all the money back to
the shareholders or
can we find something to invest in that
that's going to actually
generate more than 25 return and that
puts us to a question
so what we did in essence was split the
difference
you know if if i was in a situation
in the ideal situation you would just
buy 500 million worth of bitcoin
and put out a press release and do it
but if you did that that would be such a
shock to the outside shareholders that
the fear would be
well is someone going to sue us or
dump the stock because you were so
aggressive because they'll claim that
you took a risk
that you didn't disclose so our response
is let's disclose everybody we're
about to take a risk and after that
let's go ahead and take a risk but at
the same time let's give everybody an
insurance policy so we
we offered to buy back 250 million
dollars worth of the stock in this dutch
auction
so if you disagree with the decision to
buy bitcoin you can sell the stock back
at a
at a profit our stock was 120
we offered to buy uh the stock back at
up to 140
and so we cushioned the blow of the
investment
strategy by giving people an exit
strategy
from the equity that rotates the
shareholder base
and then we began to pursue the bitcoin
strategy as a primary treasury reserve
asset with
uh with a different shareholder base so
let me ask you a question now you know i
i like the analogy or the kind of the
awareness that hey we have this
giant bowl of ice cream that's melting
that's that's your cash pile that's
melting and the heat is basically the
money printer
that is uh causing acid inflation ice
cube that's melting and i save a 500
million dollar ice cube and it's melting
20 percent a year and it'll be gone and
fine so you needed to do something with
that you didn't want it to all melt away
so you decided to do this now a couple
quick questions
one is uh this is sort of rapid fire
i've got a couple rapid fire questions
for you
in 20 years from now what do you think
has generated more
value uh or more income to the company
to microstrategy is it the operating
income of microstrategy or the
investment income of the bitcoin it
holds
the investment income for sure okay and
then uh
you now to be to be very clear what
happened in march of 2020
is when the cost of capital goes to 25
percent
that means that every investor and all
investment income
every every investor generated 25
percent more doing nothing
right and every main street company that
worked 25
harder got nothing right right you
literally
tilt the playing field so that if you
don't
own if you own an assets you're
having the best year of the 30 years and
if you don't own assets it's impossible
to have a good year
right and um and so
so the second question is um you
uh as you acquire as you acquire more
and more bitcoin
is microstrategy bet like do you just
position the company at this point like
it's a bitcoin etf
it's like buy this buy this bitcoin
buying it
it's not a bitcoin etf everybody's
you're sloppy with those words
an etf is a company that invests in
securities
and it tries to keep its assets under
management equal to the amount of shares
of etf that it sold it's a financial
company
an etp is a similar type of company that
invests in commodities
if you create you know if you create
this bitcoin entity
that that equalizes assets under
management equal to the shares you sell
you created a bitcoin etp
we're neither of those things we're not
a finance company we're not an etf we're
not an etp we're not eq
we're not buying or selling bitcoin to
equalize assets under management
we're uh an operating company that owns
property bitcoin is property
and in that way you should think of it
as a company that like i i bought a
million acres of land in texas
or i bought a million gallons of
of fill in the blank a million bushels
of soybean
you can buy any kind of property right
and and you're holding it on your
balance sheet
as a company right that's what we uh
that's what we are now what's your
question
you are talking about like let's say the
the cost of capital
uh being 25 right because since march
that's what the s p500 has done but the
stock market goes you know it does go up
and down in years where
you know the market dips and and goes up
you know the average or you know over
time the geometric mean is whatever
seven or eight percent something like
that
so some would argue okay yes
this year assets inflated by that much
that doesn't mean
next year it's going to remain at 25 a
year um and so you have to make some
prediction right and so are you
are you basically forecasting it at 25
15 10 percent and does the decision
change
at a certain number there so
so gen first of all for the decade from
2010 to 2020 it was generally about
eight percent
like it was it was pretty consistent and
the single biggest driver
of cost to capital is the rate at which
the
broad money supply expands
and if you look at if you go google m2
money supply fed
you'll get a chart and you'll see the tr
by the way the chart's not all over the
place the chart is very consistent
seven percent slope for a decade it's
not jerking around
so it's not that volatile it was very
consistent monetary policy for a decade
then that chart goes like this straight
up 24
so if you uh if if you're going to make
a decision as an investor
and this is any investor what this this
has to do this applies to all 400
trillion dollars worth of
investors and it applies to every
company on earth they all have the same
exact thing they have to calculate which
is
you have to estimate the rate at which
the money supply will expand each year
for the next eight years
and so that's the same if you want to
figure out the signal or or the single
most important thing in the world for
everyone
but for everyone 7.8 billion people for
100 million companies for
everyone with money on earth and
everyone that earns a salary on earth
this is the big idea of the podcast you
have to estimate
the rate at which the currency is going
to expand
and if you believe the currency is going
to continue to expand
at 15 percent a year for the next eight
years
you come to one conclusion if you plug
in 10
it's a different conclusion if it's 25
it's a different conclusion so what do i
think
i think that um
15 is 15 for the next eight years is
reasonable
um if you're a pessimist you could say
if you're an optimist you could say 10
but
the money supply is expanding because
the federal reserve and the eu central
bank are buying a trillion dollars
worth of um bonds every year
each and it's also expanding because uh
the the government of the eu and the u.s
are running a multi-trillion dollar
deficit
and it is also expanding because of
trillion dollar plus stimulus
and there's no reason to think that's
going to change in the next four years
and i don't think in the next eight
years i think i think that at the point
that the democrats took control of the
senate
and the house you saw that you have um
if you could have you could have
forecasted 12 percent
inflation if it was a it was a split
government
but i think that in a
a non-split government there seems to be
remarkable consensus that we should run
deficits
continue to keep interest rates low and
continue to stimulate the economy
so what does that mean if you plug in a
number
15 it means that the risk-free interest
rate or the
the risk-free return is 15 it means you
have to generate in excess of 15
on your money every year for the next
four years in order to stay ahead of
the rate of asset inflation a reasonable
person would say
the assets are going to inflate at that
rate that's
that's pretty much what they do that
means that
if your company is not growing its cash
flows
you know at a 20 rate then it's not
going to hold value as a stock
it means that if your bond is paying you
an interest rate of less than
15 percent you're destroying value in
the bond
if your rent yield is less than 15 your
commercial real estate's destroying
value
and if you're holding cash you're losing
15 percent of it a year
that's that's the negative real yield so
once you actually embrace the idea of
asset inflation
and asset inflation equals cost to
capital equals the rate of the money
supply expansion
once you have that rate then you realize
that there's a negative
real real yield on everything
except for bitcoin
for the most part the negative real
yield on gold is three percent that's
the rate at which we mine it
or hypothecate it the negative real
yield on sovereign debt is about 12
13 the negative real yield on corporate
debt is 10 percent
every company that's got a growth rate
of less than 15 percent has got a
negative real yield on it so
you know once you do that then you can
then what you realize is
you can't really have a business
strategy as a company
unless you find a way to solve the
treasury problem
so the big idea here is
you want to fix any company sweep all
the cash flows
into bitcoin convert the treasury into
bitcoin
borrow against your future cash flows
and dollars convert that into bitcoin
finance all your fixed assets in dollars
convert that into bitcoin
and issue equity as much as you can now
at the highest valuation you can now in
dollars
and invest in bitcoin right and and
you might say why bitcoin
well because bitcoin is the apex
property it's the most scarce
monetary asset in the universe you can't
make any more of it
it's encrypted money and and what that
means is it's least likely to be
impaired by
a property tax an execution issue
um money printing
dilution counterparty risk and
corruption
so we have we have engineered a superior
asset a thermodynamically sound
technically superior asset it's placed
on a global
digital monetary network which is open
an open protocol and the combination
of apex
asset on the open monetary system
makes it the um the most disruptive
technology in the world
when you were first starting
microstrategy you were you were in the
weeds you were thinking
i have to make a product that solves a
problem
and i have to make money off of it right
now
you've gone way up the hierarchy of now
we can do whatever we want
now you can do whatever you want at what
point did you notice a shift like oh my
gosh like this business is stable
it's working it's working pretty well uh
yep it's quite predictable at what point
did that shift happen because what
you're talking about now
is quite foreign to what i think we
look we solved our problem when we
actually embraced bitcoin
i i i i could say to you oh yeah well
when i had 500 million in cash in the
bank i could and we were focused but the
problem with that
is that if you have a bunch of cash
generating zero interest the cost of
capital goes to 25 percent
then all the public company investors
forsake the company
and if the stock if if the stock market
forsakes the company the mainstream
media for stakes the company
right then the employees become dejected
because
eventually you're going to have facebook
amazon apple or google steal every one
of your employees
if you can't drive the stock up right
nobody wants to invest in a company that
makes a lot of money
growing at five percent a year i mean
it's it seems brutal to say that
but it wouldn't be true if the cost
capital was zero if we had a sound money
policy in this country
then you could hold your head up high
and say i run this great restaurant
and we made a lot of money last year
we're going to make a lot of money this
year
and our plan is to keep doing what we've
been doing and everybody pat you on the
back and say that's good that's
honorable
but if if i tell you i'm going to
devalue the cash by 25
a year or 20 a year at some point
you're driven into this cycle where
i have to either do a big acquisition to
keep my revenues growing
i have to take extreme risk and do
dilutive acquisitions
or i have to go borrow billions of
dollars to buy the stock back to
leverage up the cash flow per share
and if i don't do either those things
the investors dump the stock and they
dump the stock the employees start
feeling like
you know why don't they go work some
place cool and hot and
you're going to get all your engineers
stripped away by facebook or
or amazon or something so the truth is
when we actually fix the balance sheet
we fixed the stock and we fixed that you
know at this point
the company has five billion dollars
more than five billion dollars in assets
if the if the cost of capital remains at
let's say it goes up 20 percent if if we
print 20
more money next year i can reasonably
expect to generate a billion dollars in
investment income
which would be a you know 20 increase in
bitcoin right
but the truth is i can reasonably expect
better than that
if the cost of capital is 10 i can
reasonably expect 500 million investment
income
well all 2 000 people doing 100 000
things right perfectly for the entire
year competing against microsoft that
has
more money than god they can generate 75
million a year
okay so so the truth is the company
its future became secure when we
actually converted the balance sheet
to bitcoin because now
we don't have to struggle let me say it
a different way
i don't think any company could be
successful without a financial strategy
in the year 2021
like i wouldn't have said it three four
years ago
if you have a sound money macroeconomic
environment where the money supply is
expanding at two or three percent a year
you can go out and make things and
create things and market things and sell
things and service things
and generate cash with that and then and
that makes sense but if the money supply
is expanding at 20 percent a year
you need to own assets because
because what's happening is
no one's going to invest in any project
that doesn't generate more than the 20
percent hurdle
rate and so what who can generate
consistently risk-free
20 returns you have to be a monopoly
you have to have a digital monopoly or
some kind of monopoly so
it becomes exponentially harder to grow
and what
and so what happens next all these other
companies get squeezed out of the
ecosystem
right they're get they get decapitalized
and rendered insolvent
by by the monetary policy so i would say
that you know if i can get my st
my stock was 120 a share what is it
right now
like uh i haven't checked in the market
768.
okay so
if i if i get my stock up then i can
actually make my shareholders happy
i can change the narrative i can recruit
i can retain talent i can get that you
know i can inspire
the confidence of my customers i can
i can drive momentum and
then we can do what we want to do i
guess it's it's similar to
if you're a university and you had no
endowment
you know and or university that has a
billion dollar endowment or university
is a hundred billion dollar endowment
you know if you're a professor which
university you want to work for
if you're a student where you want to go
you know do you have a shiny building
coming or not right
at the end of the day right money is a
measure of energy
and so if you have monetary assets you
have energy and if you have high energy
you can pursue
your vision you know with integrity
and what percentage of your time now are
you spending
on this on investing the income
versus on the day-to-day of micro
strategy of just the
the business as usual making the
products that making business
intelligence products versus investing
the the income
um i am i'm the ceo but we have a
president
and the president of the company is fong
lee and he actually has day-to-day
operational responsibility for sales
marketing and even technology
development at this point
so i'm the chairman and the ceo i i
oversee the company
strategy and i oversee that
i oversee financial strategies i oversee
long-term direction and i
and i oversee technology strategy but
i'm not
i'm not in the weeds and the day-to-day
running the business
that's really left for the operating
executive team
so um about a year ago i
tweeted out that i had moved 25 of my
uh net worth into bitcoin which has now
become like i don't know
50 plus percent almost um and a friend
called me our friend who comes on this
podcast name's andrew wilkinson
very successful business guy he's got a
public company in in canada now
sort of has owns businesses that are
worth about over a billion
over a billion dollars and he called me
and he was just like hey
i just want to make sure you know what
you're doing here and you know uh like a
concerned friend and and he comes from
like kind of the warren buffett
and you know he's a warren buffett
disciple and famously buffett and munger
you know charlie mugger called bitcoin
uh rat poison and then buffett called it
rat poison squared
and so you get really intelligent people
um who are well respected for what
they've done um
talking about bitcoin so first what's
your reaction to the buffett
opinion on bitcoin i think everybody's
captured by their frame of reference
warren buffett would would you agree
that warren buffett for the most part
made money investing in stocks
yeah in non-technology stocks primarily
and and maybe
and maybe overseeing operating companies
how successful would he have been
if he did that in nigeria or let's say
zimbabwe
or argentina for the past 15 years of
venezuela
not very strategy wouldn't have worked
right
for example there is no strategy that
would work
if you were a business person in
zimbabwe when the currency collapsed
and if you look at the argentine blue
dollar uh the argentine dollar
the argentine peso actually used to be
worth a dollar
and then was worth and then it was three
pesos to the dollar
today it's on the black market they call
it the blue market it's worth about 150
pesos to the doll
there's you know if you live in a world
where you just
let's just start by assuming the
currency is strong
and we have no problem with that and
that stocks are going to work
and then let's talk about our investment
strategy
well if if you if you live in that world
and you and you can make those
assumptions
great but what if the currency weakens
at 15
a year for the next decade then um
then your strategy doesn't work so i i
think that for the most part
the world's full of successful people
but there's two things that are missing
one
they're they're assuming optimistically
that um that in the united states and
western europe
um whatever currency challenges we have
whatever weakness of
the currency we have will be rapidly
rectified
they're either in denial like here's how
you'll know
ask someone as an investor how they did
last year
if they're honest they'll say oh all my
you know the dollar crashed and all my
stocks are up
20 to 50 because the dollar is weaker
and and if they tell you oh i had a
great year all my my portfolio is up 37
or 50 because i'm a genius stock picker
right that's how you interpret the world
is the dollar weakening
or is the market getting better right
and um
so there's a lot of people that that
have been successful
in their frame of reference and so they
just attribute
the virtuous activity of you know their
virtuous stock picking
or their virtuous business strategy for
their success
right and then they wonder why everybody
else can't be like them
right right and then i think the second
part of this is
bitcoin is paradigm shift it's the first
time in the history of the human race
that we managed to put
first layer money on a digital network
i mean there is no uh there is nothing
to study
someone that's telling you they've
studied this how could you have studied
it it's like we invented fire or we
invented electricity
it's such a new invention that um
if if your friend said
i spent 47 hours studying bitcoin
right and i have the following you know
detailed concerns
about how it's going to evolve as a
dominant digital asset network
and these are the things i'm worried
about maybe with the constructive
conversation
but i i think that most people don't
they don't even
understand yet that
it's a digital monetary network they
don't even know there's a class of such
a thing it's the first
such thing in the history of the re of
the human race so
so i've created the ability to manifest
property in cyberspace using strong
encryption
and i have decentralized that network
such that no company or no ceo
or no country can be a point of failure
right this is this is um
a first in the human race that you know
this is a fire in cyberspace that's
that's burning with a trillion dollars
of energy
it's the fastest growth to a trillion
dollars of any digital network in the
history of the world
12 years and so if you embrace that
and you say okay i've got two things
going on here
i have a macro i've this is the first
time in 30 years
that the money supply the the broad
money supply in the us and europe is all
linked
and all and all collapsing at a rate
north of 20 percent
we didn't have this not in your lifetime
not in my lifetime
the last time we got something similar
since 1980
but and before night in the 70s but in
the 70s you had a bunch of different
central banks the german bank the french
bank the u.s bank the u.s was not the
world current it was like 30
of the currency trades in the 1980s it
wasn't
90 percent so we had the formation of
the eu
the eu tied all of european currency to
the dollar
that became 90 of all the currency every
other central bank tied in the dollar
so we arrive in a period in the last 12
months where
where the behavior of the u.s fed and
the expansion of the m2 money supply
is in essence weakening every currency
on earth
at the same time you've only got three
sets of currencies
you've got the strong currencies
weakening at the same rate as the dollar
you've and that's like 20 rich countries
then you've got um you've got most
currencies weakening 20 to 40 percent
more against the dollar and then you've
got the last basket of currencies
weakening
80 or more against the dollar they're
utterly collapsing
and so you have a macroeconomic
circumstance we've never seen in our
lifetime
and then you have a technology the most
disruptive technology of our life
more disruptive than google than
facebook more disruptive than youtube
more disruptive than
zoom more disruptive than than the
iphone
it took google 22 years to get to a
trillion it took amazon 24 years to get
to a trillion
it took apple 42 years to get to a
trillion it took microsoft 44 years to
get to a trillion
it took bitcoin 12.
it's some it's a monetary fire it's
burning in cyber space
and these two things together you know
by
how do you feed a monetary fire
with money
how more money than ever the money
is feeding the fire right and
anybody living in a comfortable
environment with a business strategy
that worked last year
right they're going to be
late to understand this because they
haven't had this
jarring realization
that there's something fundamentally
different but
if you lived in argentina or you lived
in lebanon and your currency
like let's take lebanon it collapses
overnight by 80
and if someone handed you an iphone and
said you can put bitcoin on this
and you won't be broke and starving
tomorrow you would have an incentive to
learn about this new technology because
your entire world
crashed around your head
but if you're living in a world where
you think you just made 30
return on your portfolio you don't quite
have the same appreciation of the
problem
yeah go ahead sam so you you it almost
is
it's almost like rooted and the decision
to do all this
is definitely shareholder stuff
shareholder value but a lot of it was
like really like well i just want to
attract
great talent um or that was definitely
a a factor how has
how many people work there now 2000
how has this impacted your ability to
recruit and retain people
it's been great for retention has been
great for recruiting we can get
we we get people first of all the
company's brand has been
amped up by a factor of a thousand i
mean a lot more people know
us now and like what's the culture like
now is it different
just more just happy bitcoin is hope
okay so let me say it a different way if
your family
has a hundred thousand dollars and you
showed up
you know today and i told you it was in
a bank in lebanon and now it's 20 000
but you can't spend it and it's going to
zero
what's your family's morale right well i
mean
yeah and if your family had a hundred
thousand in bitcoin
at the same in the same year and i told
you oh by the way bitcoins up by a
thousand percent and now you have a
million dollars and it's probably going
to keep going up forever and you don't
have to worry it's not black and white
like that
it's not black and white no it's not i'm
looking at your glass door reviews i'm
looking at the glass door reviews not
everyone agrees
uh like surely there's downside to this
i mean not everyone agrees
i i'm looking at i see a lot of bad
reviews and every great company has a
lot of bad reviews but it's not black
and white that everyone agrees i mean
you have a 43
review on glassdoor i know that
glassdoor isn't the full picture
but it's clear that not everyone agrees
with your opinion and i want to know
is that is that only stats for the past
six months
no there's a there's a thousand reviews
and it's been uh
isn't it for the past decade um but i
can sort by date so i can i can tell you
a a number by any
you could just i could set it by uh any
constraint
right now it's uh all so one thousand
reviews
within its and it's a low review um
and i and it so it doesn't seem that
everyone agrees with that are you
looking at the past 10 years
and if you go back over the past 10
years we had
we had one point where the company was
contracting
and we laid off employees and so
so no i'm looking at reviews all from
2020 there's i think
truth be told nobody gives a about
glassdoor reviews right like you know
i do i don't know i think i think i
think that
i think there's two no matter how thin
the pancake there's always two sides
but there's bits of truth in all of it
right you could you could gain
friends what is the do you what is the
point you would like to make
and what shall we discuss what i want to
know is
is what's been the downside of this
because it's not black and white that
everyone agrees with you um
it's not black and white that like this
has been perfect sam can i ask you a
question in a slightly different way
i think i get what you're trying to say
so it's not not necessarily oh
have people disagreed with you because
right now also you look like a genius
you bought the thing
the brand is up the stock is up the
bitcoin price is up like
if you really disagree now this is your
own personal problem at this point the
strategy has clearly worked up till
now the question is more that hey we've
had periods of time i've been holding
bitcoin since 2013 2014
and i've seen bitcoin go down you know
70 80 percent drawdowns and
you have basically uh taken out a bunch
of debt you bought bitcoin you own 5
billion
bitcoin the majority of the company's
value is the bitcoin that
the assets that it owns and if we do see
i think we kind of agree volatility will
dampen over time but
that doesn't mean we can't see a
drawdown like that again what happens
when bitcoin price
drops by 50 again um you know what's
your reaction to that how you know how
does that affect your strategy or what's
your
overall viewpoint of this possibility
that's not that
that's not the downside of your strategy
right yeah yeah yeah
on a day-to-day level at the company i
imagine there's a ton of people that
love this
but what is what has been any of the
downsides of this
because with every great decision
there's always going to be
downsides as well as upsides i can't see
any downside for the employees they've
all benefited
i can't see any downside for the
investors that stayed with us they've
all benefited
right i mean there are critics out there
that don't like bitcoin
and by there are people that will say
you're a ceo
you shouldn't invest it you know i there
are there are people that will say
operating companies shouldn't have
assets
right there's a cr like uh there's
criticism people say well your ceo
you should go back to your cubicle
and write software and leave the
investing to the professionals
but i think that the fundamental element
in the room here
is that the macroeconomic environment is
so incredibly unfair
to people without assets like literally
if you're an operating company or a main
street company you have to work 30
harder to stand still and if you're a
wall street company
you can stand still and get 30 more like
the playing field is so
tilted in favor of property owners
or asset holders against manufacturers
and and companies that that do things
that you you can't really be successful
in business
unless you have assets as part of your
strategy
and so so okay so me and sam were asking
different questions sam wanted to know
more about the morale
i want to know if we do see another
bitcoin
you know crash draw but draw down 50 60
uh what happens to your position and uh
what happens to your your point of view
well we we have permanent capital so it
doesn't make a difference to us right
like right now for example
we have a three billion dollar
investment gain so if you cut
bitcoin in half we would still have an
investment gain
right i mean our basis is 24 000 so
if it goes down to less than 24 000 and
stays there
forever then it will have not been a
good investment i suppose
but otherwise we we've got a long-term
strategy which is you buy it and hold it
and and i think that a lot of people
live in fear of volatility but a lot of
people live in fear of a lot of things
right
if you're if you have enough fear you
won't leave your house you won't do
anything
and so you have to have a bit of courage
and conviction
i i can give you a thousand reasons why
i think it makes sense to invest in
bitcoin
like i can't give you any reason why
why i should be afraid to do a rational
thing
so you know it doesn't really bother me
right there's this is a rational
strategy
if i had it to do all over again would i
of course i would right ask all the
investors that made billions and
billions of dollars
you know over the time frame right of
course you would do it again
uh and i think we're gonna we're gonna
have to wrap uh based on time
so appreciate you coming on uh do you
wanna leave anybody with a way to way to
find you
place to follow place to take a next
step if they you know liked what they
heard
sure if you're interested in bitcoin
bitcoin is hope so go to h-o-p-e
hope dot com we have lots of information
in it if you want to follow me i'm uh
michael underscore sailor on twitter how
much you think bitcoin.com is worth
roger vera owns it now
how much would you be paying for
bitcoin.com i don't know i i wouldn't
speculate
i wouldn't speculate you know i think
for most people a lot of what you're
saying i think is going to be
uh over their heads that listen to this
to be perfectly honest with you
um i think but but i could distill it
down into a very simple
a simple way of looking at it for
anybody that listened to this and they
were intrigued but they didn't know
they haven't you know sort of gone down
the rabbit hole yet which is
very simply if guys like michael saylor
who own public companies that
have a ton of money are worried about
what they're going to do
because their money is melting and
they're looking for
you know investment grade you know uh
sort of
uh the most powerful treasury asset and
he's decided it's bitcoin
and uh you know square has put some
money in paypal has put money in
um tesla's put a billion and a half
dollars into into bitcoin
um it's likely that there are more
companies out there and it'll take them
six months to a year to make this move
but they will take a portion of their
treasury reserves and they'll move it
into bitcoin
and these are long-term holders these
are not retail day traders that are
going to be you know buying and selling
the thing like crazy
so the real simple thing is
you can sort of invest into the network
you can buy bitcoin yourself and you can
front run the institutions that are
coming
uh that was a very simple very simple
thesis a very simple takeaway for
somebody who's listening to this if
you're a company you better be thinking
about what you're going to do
with the cash if you're an individual
person you should also be thinking about
what you're going to do with your cash
and the easy move is that for once you
get to front run the institutions
and you get to get in before they all
get in whereas typically
the retail investor is last i i think
that's
it's a a reasonable thing to say i agree
with it
another big picture way to say it is
there's a hundred trillion dollars of
treasury assets that have a negative
real yield of minus
10 to minus 15 a year that means they're
they're destroying 10 trillion dollars a
year of value
the solution is convert all of that
money
into bitcoin bitcoin's a trillion dollar
asset
the you know people that understand
bitcoin think it's going to grow to
become the 10 trillion dollar asset the
gold is
and then it's going to replace negative
yielding sovereign debt and then
corporate debt
and and ultimately it will become the
primary treasury
reserve network and treasury reserve
asset
and so if you have a company if you're
an investor it makes sense to buy it
because
it's got a brilliant future and it
solves a problem that everybody on earth
has and if you're a company
it makes sense to plug your treasury
into bitcoin
because the road to serfdom
is working exponentially harder for
currency
growing exponentially weaker right
you're just going to work yourself to
death
you know put yourself in a position of
working as hard as you can in venezuela
or argentina
or zimbabwe and roll the clock forward a
decade and ask yourself the question
what do you wish you did
and the answer is protect your assets
protect your your monetary energy or
your treasury
by putting it into a scarce asset in a
bank in cyberspace where no one can
steal it
debase it or destroy it and and that's
the bitcoin
ethos we're simply trying to we're
trying to make it worthwhile to do the
other stuff
there's no point in doing a hundred
million other things
if at the end of the journey you've got
nothing to show for it
yeah why create all the value if you
cannot store it
so here's a better store of value right
yeah but that's the big idea and that's
and that's a business strategy for
everybody small
medium large doesn't matter and you know
i'm just kind of anticipating somebody
who hears this and they say but we're
not argentina we're not venezuela do i
really need to worry about this
and what's your answer to that
my answer is the single most important
thing for you to
to have in your life is a forecast
for the money supply expansion in your
country for the next eight years
so i would say that before you
invest the next decade of your life
doing whatever
stop and study up on macroeconomics and
form an opinion
about the rate at which your currency is
going to lose
economic energy and then you can act
accordingly if you think that the
currency is going to hold
by the way the currency has never held
it's lost six percent of its value
every year forever right it's always
losing 600 value
you just have to decide for the next
decade whether or not the cost of
capital is going to be 8
12 16 or 20 and once you make that
decision
that will inform you with regard to with
what
what degree of enthusiasm will you
pursue
a hard asset strategy if you think that
the
if you think that the currency is going
to weaken rapidly
then you would shift you would um you
would shift and prioritize
hard asset strategy and hard asset
acquisition
um aggressively and if you think that
the currency is going to
not weaken that rapidly you would
prioritize
other strategies right and you
everybody's got to make that decision
for themself
but when you know when zimbabwe started
to crash normal companies
management consulting companies started
buying lumber
and coal and oil and anything they could
buy
because at least you'll still have it
tomorrow whereas the cash the currency
the receivables will be worth nothing
so you just have to make that decision
we can't there's plenty of information
in the world for you to form your own
opinion
once you've formed your opinion then
then you can act accordingly
cool all right michael thank you for
coming on gentlemen
yeah we appreciate this is great um
thank you
we just did this interview with
michael's what's this sailor or yeah
l right and no i mean i wouldn't sure if
it was sailor or sailor without an l
recap it and then explain your opinion
first objectively try to recap it
objectively uh we had this guy on uh
he's objectively successful financially
uh objectively a wonderful businessman
he came on for
he he said ahead of time his objective
for this interview was to promote
bitcoin
which that's cool we could talk about
that for a bit that
we i'm down with that i wanted to ask
him a little bit more beyond that but we
didn't get to it
and he talked for 60 plus minutes all
about this topic
and i personally pressed him on a few
topics
and he disagreed with me and my vibe
this is no all right we're past the
objective part my vibe from this
was uh i don't trust i don't trust his
opinion
okay so i'll give you my two cents and
then we'll we'll just talk about it real
quick so
i just was i thought he came on just
kind of low energy slash maybe like kind
of
arrogant i don't know smug a little bit
not in a bad way but i think at the
beginning we were clearly trying to like
warm him up just talk to him about
something and he had zero interest
in uh in chattan about uh anything
besides the virtues of bitcoin and so
that was a little bit
i don't know just personally a little
off-putting i guess like
i find it more fun when a guest comes on
and there's somebody that
you leave the podcast being like man i
want to i'd love to hang with that
person more
um i think that's a great sign for the
guest and i think in this case
you know i didn't walk away with that
feel i agree with all the things he said
objectively
he's super smart you know literally a
rocket scientist who built a billion
dollar company by the time you know a 10
billion dollar company by the time he
was
34 you know from 24 to 34 he built a 10
billion dollar company
has been running it for 30 years as a
public company ceo
went into bitcoin heavy and has made
three billion dollars in bitcoin like
you guys is definitely a smart guy and i
think ahead of the curve in many ways
i've read his book the mobile wave which
he wrote 2012 basically saying that
mobile's gonna
like mobile's gonna destroy everything
and uh
which in 2012 was a sort of safe
prediction but
uh still a good prediction nonetheless i
don't agree with you that he was
just like would you say like not
trustworthy or something so explain well
and let me just say
this is like a d jerk reaction so i
don't want
my opinion's certainly evolving as as
it's going and
and i've sean you've talked about them
all the time so that was my experience
when i read a
wikipedia page and i probably watched
the top two or three interviews that's
that that's my experience
i don't want to say distrusting but
there was something about it so
in the interview i question about
something silly not not silly i don't
think it's silly sean thinks it's silly
and that's okay i understand why someone
thinks that i
i said your glass door reviews are
pretty shitty like recently
um well no you asked a more reasonable
question you said it's all been okay
great
bitcoin's up this is your stock price is
up but like what have been the downsides
which i think is a perfectly reasonable
question to ask
and he was just like well there are no
downsides and i was like well that's
like
objectively false because there's there
there's some people they they're
anonymous and it's glass doors so that
doesn't hold a ton of weight but there's
a lot of people on your reviews that say
that this is crazy and that
your products are failing and you're
doing this to distract that
like what are the downsides and he i
think he
he kind of dodged the question and i
couldn't get the truth out of him
and because of that i'm like if i can't
trust something so obvious
or if someone can't give me a straight
answer on something i feel is so obvious
of saying like
yeah look there's a ton of upside which
i've discussed but here's some of the
downsides
then in my head i'm like well i can i
believe anything you're saying
right once you are um once you are
not reasonable or rational about one
thing i can't
fully think you're reasonable and
rational about this other thing that
you're telling me about that's kind of
what you're saying
how anything is how you do everything
and and i also think that anyone who
brags about how rational they are
are some of the least rational people um
i don't which by the way i don't think
he bragged about it i think
it's like when you ask him you know this
person is this bad thing about it he's
like well i just think it's
a clear because of this this is true
that's a rational thing in my opinion i
don't think he was saying yeah he
he never claimed he never said that
correct but he said like well this is
this is an incredibly rational decision
i don't see downsides and i'm like well
we're naturally so not rational i'll
defend his
i'll defend by the way i spent most of
the podcast basically
even though i'm a huge bitcoin bull i
spent most podcast podcasts
bringing up things that a critic of his
strategy and a critic of bitcoin
would say just because i wanted to hear
his answers but in general like
i get what he's saying that look we
bought two billion dollars worth of
bitcoin it's gained three billion more
our stock price is up i don't know 4x
since we
made this strategy change and you're
asking me like how do my employees feel
like
they feel great our brand just went up a
thousand x people know what
microstrategy is now they didn't know
what the hell it was before
our stock price is up our assets
are have we've gained a lot more value
in our assets so
what are you talking he was basically
like there's no downside that's all
upside so i get that but he didn't uh
you know give you the inch that i think
most
most reasonably people would do which is
to say that yeah everything has its
trade-offs maybe like
it would he could have said it was
really complicated to go through the
process of being the first public
company to make this huge bitcoin
purchase and so that was a huge just
you know regulatory and legal
you know like mess we had to work
through but i'm glad we did or like
you know there's always some people in
the company that disagree with the
decision and so they you know they
haven't
you know they're no longer with us or
you know they've had to get on board
with something that they didn't see as
was the right decision
and that's always tough whenever you
have strong-minded people you're not all
you can 100 agree with a
radical strategy he could have said any
of those things he didn't but
how does it make me personally distrust
him i think for you that was a turn off
i i don't want to i like i said before
the this is an all-knee jerk it just
happened i i so i want to be careful my
words if i said distrust i i actually
i take that back i don't entirely mean
distrust but i i mean that there's
something going on that i had this gut
feeling
that um i can't just believe what you're
saying
and i want to go and and this should be
the case all the time
on my own right i think it's all pretty
above board which is he's basically bet
his entire company on bitcoin now
they own five billion dollars of bitcoin
the company's worth seven billion
dollars
and bitcoin you know so obviously and
his objective his stated objective to us
coming on was to
communicate the nature and virtues of
bitcoin to the audience and leave them
excited about the opportunities that
bitcoin offers
so he wasn't there was no bait and
switch he said what he wanted to do he
tried to do that
um and it's clear that he is
incentivized for more people
companies and individuals to buy bitcoin
because he is
maybe the largest holder of bitcoin in
the world uh i don't know
i don't know what satoshi's stake is
worth now uh maybe check that out
does he have more bitcoin than satoshi
he he i don't think so
he said i think it might be the podcast
uh three billion at one point
his three billion is his gain he owned
they owned five billion dollars worth
so uh what is satoshi's stake with
either way he's one of the top five
bitcoin whales in the world he clearly
wants bitcoin to go up and wants more
people to adopt it
to me that's like you got to have a
natural discount
of what somebody's saying when it comes
to
um when they are highly highly
incentivized for you to
invest in that same thing that doesn't
mean he's wrong or he's like
doing anything dishonest it's like you
just have to know that hey this guy's
clearly
he believes it he has high conviction
and he has an incentive to make other
people believe it too
abreu what did you think
i mean i think i i just quaking in fear
right now
say what you really want to say let's
let's not let's not
uh i will say that i for the most part
agree with what you guys said
i mean talking about michael himself
like super intelligent
but professorial he like he doesn't make
for a great guest and you see this on
other podcasts as well like when joe
rogan has like
some kanye well-renowned like super
intelligent like scientists on
sometimes they're you know they're they
they just want to go on about their
field and their studies and
um so those will make for the best guess
so i'll say that
um yeah which is kind of sad because you
know from my point of view
my i i guess we both walked away from
the podcast feeling a little
disheartened or i don't know like
whatever uh we didn't we didn't feel
like we we had a slam dunk
um i think you for a different reason
than me for me it was just
i didn't think it was highly
entertaining for people and i'm kind of
bummed about that because i actually
think it's a super
i think he's a super interesting
guy has had a super interesting life and
business story
and also what he's doing with bitcoin i
think is super interesting
so somehow despite there being an
underlying like substance that is super
interesting i don't think it got
communicated i almost wish
i could just do a billy of the week
segment just explaining everything i
know about michael saylor doing the
right
yeah for this interview i think that
would be way more entertaining than
what actually happened when he came on
was basically talking about
quite technical you know economically
technical terms that i think for most
people they're not going to resonate
with it's not going to click
and doing it in a way that was sort of
like
it didn't feel like somebody who
was trying to break it down and make it
more accessible it was just like this it
is what it is
and i can sort of explain it in bits and
pieces to you if you want and if you
don't see it
you're crazy you know what one of the
best parts was towards the end sean when
you like took a few minutes and kind of
explained
what we just talked about in a high
level i thought that was like the
easiest part to digest the whole thing
and
more that should have been more of what
the podcast was and unfortunately it
wasn't
and it wasn't for a lack of research as
far as like the interview not being that
great like we put you guys put a ton of
research into this
um i think sometimes just the guest
personality doesn't
make for the the best podcast well i
think people can listen to it
uh it's an hour long i i i want to say i
appreciate him coming on
michael's a big deal uh uh i i
definitely appreciate him coming on
i'm gonna i want to i definitely want to
take back like you know the whole
i don't trust him entirely but uh
there's something sitting
there after that interview there's
something sitting right where something
inside me is like
uh something is going on here and i
gotta figure out what it is
um maybe we can have him on another time
now that we kind of like know him a
little bit more
but uh yeah i'm sure aside for
themselves
you know actually it'll be kind of
interesting because we're gonna leave
this in by the way like the
whatever our discussion about it and i
hope i hope it kind of gets received as
what it is this is a instant hot take
reaction to something that we were
really excited about
then it happened we're giving a quick
reaction i think
uh you know sam basically uh didn't see
the the kind of the bitcoin bull case as
black and white as
maybe michael taylor first of all like
let me just say that
i when i my opinion of him is totally
separate of bitcoin i would say i'm a
i'm a huge novice i'm not an expert but
uh i felt that he was actually uh he he
was a
poor representation of it because
there's something about it that i'm like
oh i don't know if i could trust this
right because he's representing it you
weren't buying what he was selling i
don't know i don't know how to put it
but
nothing no attack on his character you
just didn't walk away from listening to
the guy for the hour and you didn't
fully um buy in like we do sometimes
with certain guests where they start to
explain what's going on in their field
or their business and we walk away
saying
that guy knows what he's talking
about and like i totally agree with the
way the world is going and i want to
invest in that guy's company you know
that's
sometimes the way we feel he didn't
persuade me if
if that was his goal i don't think it i
don't think goal was not achieved
can i give people the like i'm gonna can
i try a three minute
like billy of the week segment on this
guy real quick this is your podcast you
do what you want yeah go for it oh i
mean
are you interested i don't know if
you're interested okay so let's do it
here's here's okay michael saylor to me
is uh you know more than the billy of
the week he might be the billy of the
month
uh okay so here's some cool things about
him that i found doing some research for
this so
the guy's a badass he you know graduates
first in his class in high school
valedictorian
he's voted most likely to succeed he
goes to mit
on a like you know rotc you know
scholarship
he goes to the air force he wants to be
kind of like a fighter pilot
and um you know eventually like you know
he i think for whatever reason he
he wasn't going to be able to be a
fighter pilot i think some he didn't
pass one of the physicals or something
like that
um and so he's like you know because
they have a very strict requirement for
that
so anyways he decides that 20 uh he's
he's working at dupont i don't know if
he knew this part sam
he's he works at dupont when he's like
right out of uh college basically
and he's doing simulations for dupont
and dupont's trying to make a
billion-dollar decision should we invest
in this or not
and if anybody's been in a big company
you know that when an executive trying
to make a case
for when the executive wants to do
something it's sort of their pet project
they don't really want the simulation to
be this really objective case of
pros and cons they kind of just want
some data to support what they already
want to do
so they can go get a billion dollars of
funding to go do the thing they want and
so he builds the simulation and the
simulation basically says
don't do it and anyways he he ends up
just like leaving dupont he's like i
don't know why the hell i'm at this
company they just they didn't even want
the results of the simulation they just
wanted me to say
what needed to be said so that some
executive could go pitch their case
so i'm leaving this place and the
executive is basically like hey where's
that kid who's doing that model i need
that data
and he's like um he's like and they're
like he left the company he quit
and so the guy's like go hire him back
give him what he wants and so they go to
him and they say hey we want to hire you
back and we'll give you more money and
he's like i don't really want to work
there so i don't want more money
and then the executive's like give him
more we'll give him what is it whatever
he wants just give it to him and he's
like well
i kind of want to start my own company
so why don't we do this you give me a
quarter million dollars
and i want to hire some of my colleagues
from dupont i want to hire eight to ten
people from there
and um i want you to be my first
customer so i want you to give me you
know a few million dollars worth of
contracts
to do work for you and i'm gonna start
my company microstrategy which does the
same simulating thing for companies and
you'll be my first customer
so pretty badass negotiation he goes and
instead of being an employee he
basically gets dupont to seed fund
his company and become a multi-million
dollar customer for him
so from there he's 24 years old that's
microstrategy how it starts basically
what they do is like
what's called business intelligence or
executive intelligence they they take
all the data you have so like
your victoria's secret you have all this
data of purchasing and all your stores
all across the country
microstrategy goes in and says hey
you're carrying the wrong sizes you need
bigger bras in chicago than in new york
so if you rebalance your inventory
you're going to save all this money and
uh there's data you're sitting on this
gold mine of data you just don't know
how to analyze it we can give you
intelligence
from this data so he does that for
mcdonald's and for victoria's secret and
all these different companies
by 34 he's a billionaire the company's
public it's worth 11 billion dollars he
owns the majority of the company owns
over 50
and he's doing his thing now over time
2003 2004 stock price crashes from 333
dollars a share
to 42 cents a share or something like
that and you know he goes through that
whole transition he's been the ceo of
microstrategy
for like 30 years like literally i was
born in 1988
sam's born in 1989 he's been the ceo of
microstrategy since 1989.
you know like that's pretty pretty wild
and more recently like you know
microstrategy has been flat for like a
decade stock price not really going
anywhere
business is profitable he's got 500
million dollars of cash in the bank
but the stock price is not growing and
he's like 500 million dollars i think
personally he said
uh no i think in this case it was the
corporate treasury we had about 560
million dollars he owns
the majority of the company i think he
owns currently no i think i think in the
podcast he was like
i have whatever he he's basically he was
incredibly wealthy and the company was
great he's incredible and the company's
incredibly wealthy and he basically
comes to this realization during the
coveted crash and he's talked about this
on other podcasts which is
it comes to this realization that um
wait a minute if the money supply you
know we hear about government stimulus
we hear governments printing
two trillion dollars six trillion
dollars 13 trillion dollars total
uh the money supply is increasing which
means if you had 500 million dollars in
the bank
if you go back and look it'll still save
500 million dollars but it won't be able
to buy you
as much as it did before because there's
all this trillions of new dollars in the
in the
in the in the money supply and
similarly like uh people have been
wondering during covid
wait a minute all the businesses are
shut down and people are locked in their
homes why are all the stock prices at
like all-time highs
what's this disconnect between main
street and wall street and what he's
pointing out
i think rightfully so is that when you
have all this money printing
assets inflate basically assets like
companies inflate so that's why the
stock
prices are going up it's not that you
know um
zoom or you know zoom's a bad example
it's not that apple is making
all all this much more money than they
were three months ago
it's that apple stock is more of a hard
asset to own
versus own just keeping cash in dollars
which is getting printed and diluted
essentially by the government
right so long story short microstrategy
goes out and they
they basically do this aggressive
aggressive um
aggressive strategy to buy a quarter
billion dollars of bitcoin
they're kind of the first public company
to go do such a bold bet
and then he keeps buying bitcoin um more
and more and more he's basically bought
two billion dollars of bitcoin so first
he took all the money they have
a majority of the money they have and
they bought bitcoin with it
um and and he first announced it and he
told his shareholders look we're going
to buy a bunch of bitcoin with our cash
if you don't want to hold our shares
we'll buy your shares back from you
if you don't like that strategy so they
bought 60 70 million dollars back
they use the rest of the cash to buy
bitcoin then he starts issuing debt he
goes and raises 500 million dollars he
goes raises a billion dollars of debt
from the public markets
takes all that money buys bitcoin with
it and so since then he's basically
put in two billion dollars he's gained
three billion dollars and he has a total
stake of bitcoin of five billion dollars
which i think makes him makes
microstrategy you know a top five
owner of bitcoin in the world um you
know just behind satoshi and maybe a
couple others
and since then you know famously elon
tweeted out something about
bitcoin michael saylor responded saying
hey from one rocket scientist to another
let me show you how we let me explain to
you why we did it and you should too
and a few months later tesla goes and
buys 1.5 billion dollars of bitcoin so
he's kind of was ahead of the curve on
this stuff
um in addition to that some other cool
things
early on in the doc he sort of
identified early on that the internet
was going to be a big deal and bought a
bunch of domains so we spent about
two million dollars buying domains like
alarm.com
alarm.comwisdom.comstrategy.com
michael.com mike.comangel.com
courage you know hope and he owns all
these premium domains one word english
word domains
and he has since you know sold or
created businesses under those domains
for you know over a hundred billion
dollars so he turned
you know one or two million billion one
or two million dollars
sorry one or two million dollar domain
purchases into over 100 million dollars
of value um he also has this thing
called sailor.org which is just like a
free education it's just a free
university
um and he said you know since 1999
they've had
over half a million students in it so
this guy's done a bunch of cool
and i think is like a pirate of the best
kind like
super smart technologist super smart
business guy
has just been in the game for so long
and is doing pretty radical things
so that's why you know i think this
guy's a baller unfortunately i didn't
feel that all that came through on the
podcast but
you know i'm a fan well i i think
michael uh and his team will reach out
and say thank you sean because i think
that you did an
awesome job of uh you did a better job
of showing
showing off him than him uh
which is cool and uh i think
i think you're just you're just better
at storytelling so
maybe maybe uh maybe people will have a
uh
the same opinion after this interview
the the part that i
uh kind of was like i don't know how i
feel about this it happens like
probably 15 minutes left in the episode
maybe a brayu or someone will uh
mark it uh and you guys will be able to
hear it for yourselves
but uh i think sean you're just really
good at this and uh i guess we'll see uh
this episode is gonna be weird it's i
wonder what the people are gonna say i
guess we'll find out
yeah same all right cool
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i'll put my all in it
like no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back